if you want to keep your dog occupied
for hours potentially while you are gone
or working or whatnot then there are a
few things you can do one of my
favorites is to provide them with a
wobble ball you can actually feed them
their breakfast through this if you want
to journal for instance and it looks
something like this you have this
particular device is one of my favorites
it is a Starmark wobble ball and there
are two entrances you can see here that
you can modulate the size of this
opening depending on how quickly you
want to come out of what says kibble you
have and then there is a separate way to
titrate or determine how quickly the
rate of dispersal comes and that is with
the second here so you can load into the
top it will fall from the first chamber
into the second and then the dog will
move it back and forth to knock it out
and consume it this is a nice touch but
can sometimes backfire this is a little
strapped dog can use to hurl it around
the room and what I would say is that
unlike the for instance wobble balls
that are made by the Kong company there
are two advantages to this and one
disadvantage the first advantage is that
you can more accurately determine how
quickly pieces come out so you can
determine if it takes ten minutes or an
hour the downside and is very easily
remedied instead if you have a hardwood
floor as I do in many places your dog
will often determine that it is
hilarious and very entertaining to throw
this in the air and have it come
smashing down on something hard like
hardwood or linoleum or marble or
whatever might crack so you simply take
it off and there you have it that is how
I will oftentimes put on bose
noise-canceling headsets and journal
while my dog eats breakfast for an hour
to an hour and a half enjoy thanks so
much for watching guys and be sure to
consider signing up for my email
newsletter by clicking on email
newsletter because I share private q and
A's exclusive content awesome things
like five bullet Friday's which is the
five coolest things I've discovered in a
given week exclusively via email and
that's for the die hard that's for the
people who really want
the main line of usefulness and how-to
and to really ride along with me as I
learn and discover the most useful
things that I find so check it out
email newsletter click on it and please
let me know what you would like more of
in terms of video in terms of audio I
will try to make it for you so let me
know in the comments and thank you again
for watching